all right so we've got a sphere it's
sort of a shell or a sphere and then
there's a thing for it to stand on
little base there's a hole on top and
there's this pattern this cool pattern
sort of Pentagon's and so on and I've
got a flashlight or torch if you haven't
been in America for too long you can
take the the sort of lens off and you
just get like a it's supposed to be like
like it's like a candle or something but
what I want to use it for is to show
this thing stereographic projection so
if I put the lights right at the North
Pole of the sphere then you get this
pattern of shadows so right so what is
geographic projection it's a map from
the sphere to the plane and the light
rays sort of do that map a light ray
comes from the North Pole and let's say
this one here right so it hits the point
on the sphere here and it goes down to
the the table here to the plane so you
can see like if I put my little finger
near to this point on the sea you can
see the shadow on the plane is where
it's where it's going to it was one of
the first way that people thought about
like maps of the earth or the heavens
where the celestial stuff so the Greeks
knew about this stuff and all of the old
kind of star maps are done with
stereographic projection so one of the
things that's really cool about it is it
preserves angles and you can see on this
model is always like three or six 60
degree angles here it's like it's like a
radiation symbol here and the shadow has
these 60 degree angles and the sphere
also has those 60 degree angles so not
only does it preserve angles like angles
stay the same it also preserves circles
you can see on this as all these great
circles like an equator of the sphere
well actually this one doesn't have an
equator if this is North Pole those and
then quite a drawn in but like the path
that you take if you just start setting
in a straight line around the Earth is
this circle that's like an equator if
you look at where is this path on down
on the shadow think it's this one here
and you'll see that it's a circle there
as well so to see the circles a little
bit better maybe let's let's have a look
at this one it's got circle the place is
kind of like a dodecahedron I
coffee-drinking with circles let's see
what kind of shadow this makes and if I
hold the light in the right place you
can see so this circle up here
goes to this circle down here so yes
somehow it knows that circles are
supposed to be circles even though
things are getting kind of weirdly
distorted right the size of the circles
changes a lot on the plane they're all
the same size on the spherical but it
still knows that they should be circles
right I mean you know if you move it
somewhere else then like it has to be
right at the North Pole sit to work in
the same thing with the angles there's
not as a North Pole it's not serigraph a
projection doesn't have all these nice
properties so here's a yet another right
pattern on a sphere which is sort of
weird curvy thing going on so well
what's this going to make you may be
surprised well let's find out and put
this in there's this perfectly regular
square grid hiding inside of this really
curvy round thing well the way I made
this is I started with the square grid
and then I put it back up onto the
sphere to see what's going on so I could
just continue making this square grid
going further and further out and then
I'm going to get closer and closer into
the North Pole but I'll never actually
get to the North Pole like the North
Pole somehow corresponds to going
infinitely far out this way
going infinitely many squares eventually
well I wouldn't ever get to the North
fault but that's what the North Pole
corresponds to the North Pole isn't
there it's a once one thing every point
on the sphere gets a point on the plane
apart from the North Pole so so the
plane plus one point at infinity
infinitely far away is the same as the
sphere this is a two-dimensional surface
goes through the two-dimensional plane
let's go one dimension down let's do
that so the equivalent of the sphere the
2-dimensional sphere is the
one-dimensional circle right it looks
like a line if you just look at the
pieces let's do all the the table and
then my light is going to be here at the
North Pole of this circle right a circle
is sort of a one dimensional version of
the of the sphere and so you know a
light ray comes down here and it hits
the sphere somewhere and hits the plane
somewhere and that's the map
stereographic projection takes you from
here to here and so you know what we
were doing is okay squares are marching
off this way and like you know there's
there's another Square and so there's
another line that goes out here and the
corresponding point on the sphere gets
closer to the North Pole and you get
closer
and this line goes off and you get
closer when this line goes off but you
never like nor full itself is somehow
like infinitely far away circle same
thing as the line plus a point and then
we had the sphere in ordinary
three-dimensional space is the same
thing as the two dimensional plane plus
one point the North Pole infinitely far
away spear in two-dimensional space
sphere in three-dimensional space sphere
in 4-dimensional space okay so if we're
in four dimensional space we can still
measure things and we can still say the
sphere right it's the thing which is the
set of points which are at some distance
from the center and we can't see it you
can't you know this is four dimensional
but same thing the sphere is the same
thing as the three dimensional plane
space whatever plus the point at
infinity so or in other words I can't
show you this sphere in 4-dimensional
space but I can show you the shadow the
shadow is going to be a three
dimensional thing so we can see it but
we can 3d print it or we can do computer
animations or something it gets give you
some idea of what this thing in four
dimensions is so here what were we doing
we were like drawing squares on the
sphere and three dimensional spacemen
casting the shadow so we're going to
draw something else on the sphere in
4-dimensional space and cast a shadow so
what are we going to be drawing monkeys
so this is a like a monkey design like
so so you're sketchy of sketching
something on the surface of this sphere
so just like you know you're drawing
some two-dimensional picture here I need
to draw a three-dimensional picture on
this sphere in 4-dimensional space and
the three-dimensional picture I'm going
to draw is this monkey or it's going to
be a slightly distorted version of this
monkey so what what could you draw it
with like like three-dimensional paint
well yeah I mean like like the sphere in
4-dimensional spaces of
three-dimensional things so anything
free dimensional you can put it on there
in the same way for anything
two-dimensional on a two-dimensional
sphere surface whatever so really this
is drawn on one cubical side of a
hypercube whatever and then it gets sort
of really projected out onto the sphere
in for
no space once you're on the sphere then
we can do this stereographic projection
make a three-dimensional shadow of it in
three-dimensional space which we can see
this is the monkey inside of one cube of
the hypercube and he's so this this cube
has six neighbors so this monkey needs
six neighbors and they're all kind of
like twisting around in various ways
this is showing kind of some kind of
crazy four-dimensional symmetry group
that's why the monkey is there is it's a
motif that's showing this symmetry we
get our four-dimensional flashlight
and/or torch whatever depending on your
Commonwealth status and you project it
down to three dimensional space and we
see what it looks like we can figure it
out and we can see it without poor
three-dimensional brains that can't deal
with four-dimensional stuff there are
people who claim they can see in four
dimensions but I think they're lying
right so this is eight monkeys
I'm a showing this particular kind of
four-dimensional symmetry so maybe you
can see this was like there's a ring of
for monkeys one two three four going
around like this and they're all sort of
standing on each other's heads and then
there's another ring of four monkeys
that go through here one two three four
and there's a particular kind of sort of
twisting symmetry that sends like this
monkey to this monkey to this monkey to
this month in it and they kind of screw
twist around as you go through there's
an animation you'll show the animation
maybe we'll make sense really right some
people get like really weirded out by
this they date they like you know this
is they're sort of disturbing the shapes
of them but it's just math like this is
just what it does for the monkey there's
no emotional content intended take some
it what you will I guess that's not
right you can do whatever you want with
it it's your fault you gave them the
horrific faces though that's not the
fault of math you fuck he's happy look
at this happy monkey I mean maybe he's a
little bit annoyed that his his friend
is standing on his head but so this is
the fun part so this is a this is a fun
story actually just oh yeah well
actually so oh it's still going yeah so
so they're printed right 3d printed in
is
they would like plastic dust that gets
melted they're Hollow but in shipping
some dust gets shaken out so they you
know gradually sort of lose dust we can
yeah everything gets covered in white
das that's from the 4th to me it is it
is is four dimensional monkey dust now I
could have made this less of a problem
that the issue is like the mouth is the
only exit hole right if there were two
exit holes in the monkey then you could
blow air through it and blow all the
dust out but where are you going to put
another hole in the monkey I mean you
already have monkey butts all it like
you cannot take a photograph of this
that doesn't involve a monkey butt and
if they were eight yet now so this is
eight monkeys which and there's one
monkey in each cube of the hypercube
that cute the high peak you as eight
eight cubes in it so this is a
particular symmetry that comes sort of
associated with hypercube so there's
these other four dimensional versions
with Platonic solids so there's
something called a 24 cell and you do
the same thing with 24 monkeys so this
one there were these two chains of for
monkeys each had to head to foot head to
foot this one also has these these
chains of monkeys so the best one is
probably this one right in the middle
one two three four five there's a chain
of six monkeys here going head to foot
and you can spot these other chains of
monkey so there's another chain of six
monkeys so as always I think four
different chains of six monkeys because
4 times 6 to 24 good 24 cell and just
going one step further because why not
you can do the same thing with 120 cell
120 monkeys this isn't actually the
whole thing so this is only up to the
equator of the sphere in 4-dimensional
space so this is only showing the
southern hyper hemisphere and me
hypersphere whatever
so there should be more monkeys out here
you can see like they're trying to grab
on to things but there are no more
monkeys out there just as they would get
enormous but okay so it was like chains
of monkeys this one has a chain of ten
and again you can you can do these
animations where those monkeys are sort
of slowly moving along those chains
twisting as they go means showing
different four dimensional symmetries
that don't really exist in
three-dimensional space even why you
know this thing I mean it's not actually
fair because you know there's different
like the six dents taken out of this one
as wondering you know or get forgetting
all that suppose it was an ordinary you
know just a perfect mathematical cube